you there
yeah yeah sorry the line just cut oh no
no no
no matt's working on your piece right
now i mean yeah you got a quick question
for you matt
i mean you know you've been through a
lot
and um you know you've gone to jail for
a long time too like you've got a lot of
time to kind of think [ __ ] through
i'm just wondering like what advice
would you have for for someone
my age who's much younger um you know
just to
looking back at your life like what
would you have done obviously apart from
the mortgage fraud and going to jail for
12 years like
what would you do differently to kind of
have a better life like either mentally
or just in terms of your
your job or you know your lifestyle
stop don't look at me like i'm gonna say
something profound because i'm not
waiting for it because i mean honestly
and this is like horrible
because like all of my advice when
people ask me this and people ask me
this all the time believe it or not
for some reason they think i'm inspiring
which is something i've never gone for
let me just give you a little bit of
words of wisdom mad matt's a false
prophet first of all
yeah so basically all my only advice is
the same advice any father gives
anybody it's like the same [ __ ] your dad
says it's like
it's like you know i mean you work hard
be patient
don't try and keep up with the jones you
know i mean it's
it's it's a i mean it doesn't the thing
is you know how many times keep up with
jones
you know how many times i and i and i
find myself doing this
danny's going to mock me but it only
because he knows deep down it's true
um but i mean i i actually danny
actually has a pretty good
like danny could drive he could drive a
super nice flashy car
he doesn't you know what i'm saying like
like i noticed that danny puts his money
where it's where it's smart and not
where it's flashy to let everybody know
hey look i'm a big shot
and i find myself doing the same thing
constantly where it's like i want to get
a new
nice car that i pull up in a really nice
car and i think what are you doing bro
you're going to put money into a car
that's going to depreciate like
like i'm trying to reinvest into things
that will make me money i'm trying to
not do things because
it will impress other people and that's
the problem is that i think most people
are trying to impress people that
basically don't like them anyway
and they're not patient they want things
right away they don't want to work for
it
they don't want to save they and and
just
in my opinion that that's like a huge
downfall is like i have to get the
bigger house
i have to have the better car i have to
have why
what does it matter i mean why do you
want to get something that you can
afford
save your money be smart be humble
be appreciative life is so
[ __ ] good out here and people
have no clue how good they have it you
could be a jew
in 1938 germany
you could be an african-american
african-american
in the 18th century in new orleans you
know
you could be i mean there's so many
horrible
horrible situations you could have been
born into and the truth is
life is amazing here and people just
don't appreciate it and i mean that to
me but to me that's like that's not
words of wisdom that's just the same
thing that your dad would tell you
so i don't think i don't think that
that's profound i think that that's just
something
something that i didn't believe it's
like you know what it reminds me it was
like it's like money can't buy happiness
you know but
everybody wants to find out for
themselves so
you know it's like but i've had money
and i was never happy
i was never really happy i didn't even
realize how miserable i was
outside free with tons of money until i
had nothing and i was laying in a
in a bed in prison where i realized how
unhappy it was i was
i was super happy in prison writing
happier in prison writing than i am
right now
because i'm now having to struggle to
make bills to do this and i not really
don't have the time
to write like i want to write so
it doesn't make sense but the truth is
is if you
gave me a million dollars the only thing
that million dollars would do was it
give me time
to start writing which is something i
like to do that's all the million
dollars would do
it wouldn't change me it wouldn't make
me happy it'd just give me a little bit
more freedom that's all it would do
that was that was moving i'm touched
so i told you to mock me some people
just can't help themselves
yeah that's honestly that's uh that's
amazing advice so basically just
you know do what you want to do and
don't really care what other people
think
essentially yeah i mean think about it
yes too i mean
don't get sucked up into all the fake
[ __ ] on youtube and all the ads
you want to make more money on amazon i
make a hundred grand a day on amazon
follow me at grantcardone.com and join
my pyramid scheme i mean all that shit's
so
[ __ ] whack bro
yeah yeah man there's way too much of
that [ __ ] it's crazy like everybody
wants to get rich quick and not do
anything everybody wants to be a guru
everyone thinks they have the answers
and they want to sell you a course
yeah just do what you want no i mean
dude do whatever
they do what makes you happy do what
makes you happy i mean
do what makes you happy and don't focus
so much on making money because
ultimately making money is not going to
make you happy do it what you want
you know do it what makes you happy and
the money will come i mean
in the end if you're good at something
if you're the best at something you're
going to make money at it
but don't take a job because it it pays
a bunch of money
don't do something just for the money i
would find something that you love to do
and do that and stop worrying about
keeping up most people take jobs because
they can
they want money to buy [ __ ] to impress
people that [ __ ] hate them
they don't like you anyway everybody
that i made i stole all this money
and bought a bunch of stuff to impress a
bunch of people and when i went to jail
nobody was there you know who was there
my mother
it is nice though living in a nice house
like when you have like a nice
a nice house with a pool and like yeah
it's a big space and a big yard
i mean it's better it's better a cat
it's better than living in a 500 square
foot apartment i will tell you that
but don't get don't put the car the uh
what's it called the cart in front of
the horse
yeah yeah don't put the cart before that
don't do that take your time you got
time
oh how are you i'm 30.
oh bro you can make three or four bad
decisions and still come out on top
yeah you'll still be all right
it's funny because your advice really
kind of
hits me pretty hard because uh right now
i have a job that i i do like
um but you know it's a regular job you
know it's like a nine to five and
i mean it does pay it does pay really
well but
i'm at a point where like i get really
bad
tendonitis right and like really bad
when i work
and i'm at the point where i'm trying to
decide whether i should quit my job and
just focus on my health
and just do something else that i like
what's the job if you don't mind me
asking
i'm a financial planner tendinitis
yeah he's typing all yeah oh your hands
yeah i've had really bad tendinitis over
the years and it's kind of gone up you
know in my neck and in my back and
anyways it affects my quality of life a
lot just to be at a computer all day
working
so i'm at a point now where i'm trying
to decide you know do i keep
this job for the money or do i just do
something else
and you know try to do something where i
can actually feel good
physically so yeah the advice kind of
hits me pretty hard thanks for that
i think it applies absolutely yeah
i